[Applaudissements]
bah ouais bah elle sent que ça sent pas
bon pour des huit sur est pour elle a
laissé d'aller chez le rat comme ça il
nous laisse quand même allez c'est parti
allez je vais détendre l'ambiance avec
un petit tour de magie ça me coûte 2
secondes et ça dépend toujours
l'ambiance ça fait un an et demi j'ai ça
dans la manche
c'est pas mal la belle andalouse et clip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
come back to me ou jamais donné à lui
pensant que le port du voile et les
poteaux risée et on continue on y va
j'ai maté du sport à la télé les amis
j'ai vu plein de trucs
grâce au sport je vous le dis les
secours altéré sa coupe les images j'ai
eu plein de choses déjà le supporter